Sich türmende Arbeit, ständig auf Abruf:
Bis vor einem Jahr arbeitet Mark
Brandner als Unternehmensberater
und IT-Controller für internationale Firmen.
Er ist unterwegs in der ganzen Welt,
arbeitet 60 bis 70 Wochenstunden.
Er genießt es, sich immer bereit
zu zeigen für noch mehr Leistung.
Ich wollte unbedingt vorne dabei sein,
wollte bei meinem Chef gut dastehen,
wollte bei der Firma gut dastehen.
Man bekommt ja auch ab und zu
mal auf die Schulter geklopft.
Man kriegt ’ne gewisse
Wertschätzung zurück,
die allerdings keine
richtige Wertschätzung ist.
Das ist ’ne absolute Fehleinschätzung.
Es ging immer darum:
weiter, weiter, weiter, fertig machen.
Mark Brandner muss immer mehr Umsatz
für Kunden und die Firma bringen.
Dieser hohe Druck und die Angst,
dabei zu versagen,
lassen ihn rund um die Uhr arbeiten.
Anzeichen von Erschöpfung ignoriert er,
bis er eines Tages buchstäblich
nicht mehr kann.
Immer, wenn was Neues kam,
habe ich dazu Ja und Amen gesagt –
„ja, kann ich auch noch machen, ja, kann
ich noch machen, kann ich noch machen“ –
und hab die Sachen
aber nicht mehr gemacht.
Ich hab’s von A nach B gelegt, ich hab dann
wieder ’ne Excel-Tabelle geöffnet und ...
ich wusste, was mein Job war,
ich wusste, was ich zu tun hatte,
und ich wusste auch fachlich, in welche
Richtung das geht. Aber ich hab gemerkt:
Ich mach nichts mehr.
Dann hab ich das wieder weggelegt
und hab das Nächste wieder geöffnet.
Aber ich saß zu dem Zeitpunkt
vorm Rechner,
und es ist einfach nichts mehr passiert.
Der heute 33-Jährige findet keine Erholung
und hat immer weniger Antrieb.
Er sucht sich ärztliche Hilfe.
Die Diagnose:
eine mittelschwere Depression –
hervorgerufen durch
eine tief greifende Erschöpfung.
Mazda Adli ist Chefarzt der Fliedner-Klinik
in Berlin, die sich unter anderem
auf die Behandlung psychosomatischer
Erkrankungen spezialisiert hat.
Häufige Ursache: Burnout.
Also, die meisten klagen über
psychische und körperliche Erschöpftheit,
gepaart mit der Unfähigkeit,
sich zu erholen.
Es ist dann quasi nicht mehr möglich,
den Akku wieder aufzuladen.
Und was uns aufmerken lässt als Ärzte, ist,
dass die Zahlen
in den letzten Jahren ansteigen.
Das spiegelt sich wider
in der Anzahl der Fehltage.
Eine Untersuchung hat ergeben:
Auf 1000 Mitarbeiter kamen in Deutschland
im Jahr 2006 20 Fehltage.
Im Jahr 2016 waren es bereits 110.
Dabei kann das Gefühl, völlig ausgebrannt
zu sein, jeden treffen –
ob als Pfleger, Dienstleister
oder Vorstandsvorsitzender.
Und wir wissen auch:
Menschen, die aufgrund von
seelischen Ursachen krank werden,
haben dann auch noch besonders
lange Ausfallperioden.
Und das ist natürlich etwas,
was nicht nur für den Einzelnen
und für die Angehörigen belastend ist,
sondern auch für die Volkswirtschaft.
Eine Studie der WHO prognostiziert
den Verlust
von rund 50 Millionen Arbeitsjahren
weltweit aufgrund psychischer Leiden.
Das entspräche einem wirtschaftlichen
Schaden von rund
einer Billion Dollar pro Jahr
bis zum Jahr 2030.
Die Lösung: Geld investieren
in Prävention und Behandlung.
Denn laut Studie verringert
jeder Dollar die Ausfallkosten
und führe zu einer
höheren Arbeitsproduktivität
im Wert von vier Dollar.
Sechs Monate war
Mark Brandner in Behandlung.
Ohne sie wäre er vermutlich
über Jahre ausgefallen.
Nach seiner Therapie versucht er,
wieder in seinem alten Job Fuß zu fassen.
Doch diese verdichtete Welt
passt nicht mehr zu ihm.
Er wagt stattdessen eine Kehrtwende
um 180 Grad,
macht sein Hobby zum Beruf ...
Ganz saubere Trennung ...
und [ich] arbeite jetzt im Prinzip
als Segellehrer und als Skipper,
bin viel im Mittelmeer unterwegs.
Und Geld: ja, keine Frage,
deutlich weniger Geld,
viel, viel weniger Geld,
weniger als die Hälfte.
Ist aber ... Es ist egal.
Es hat den Stellenwert so ’n
bisschen verloren,
weil ich festgestellt habe:
Es macht halt nicht glücklich.